Winning an Oscar is the highest honor an actor
or actress can receive, but unfortunately,
there are only four acting trophies handed
out at each ceremony.
This means that there are plenty of stellar
performances that go home empty handed every
year, even if millions of viewers deem them
awards worthy.
It’s always an honor just to be nominated,
but some thespians out there would love to
receive a little gold man of their own one
day very soon, and their fans are constantly
rooting for them.
Here are 10 amazing actors who are long overdue
to win an Oscar.
Amy Adams
Now that Leonardo DiCaprio has claimed his
first Best Actor prize, Amy Adams has arguably
seized the overdue narrative all for herself.
One of the finest actresses of her generation,
Adams has been nominated five times five times,
most recently for 2013’s American Hustle.
She always gives it her all, but she still
hasn’t emerged from an Oscar race victorious
yet.
Her best chance might have been The Fighter,
but in a cruel twist of fate, she lost to
co-star Melissa Leo, who was nominated in
the same category.
Adams headlines Arrival and Nocturnal Animals
this fall, two projects building Academy Award
buzz, so maybe her cold streak will end in
2016.
Andy Serkis
Chances are, you’ve heard the name Andy
Serkis, but are unfamiliar with what he actually
looks like.
Serkis was one of the leading pioneers in
the art of motion-capture acting, bringing
a new sense of realism to digital characters.
His standout roles include Gollum in Lord
of the Rings and Caesar in the new Planet
of the Apes films.
The Internet has been campaigning for Serkis
to get an Oscar for years, but Academy rules
disqualify him since he doesn’t actually
physically appear on-screen.
Still, many are hoping that he receives a
Special Achievement award one day for his
contributions to the industry, which has made
so much possible in a short amount of time.
Gary Oldman
Oldman is one of those actors who can truly
transform and fully embody his roles, so it’s
shocking that he’s only been nominated for
one Oscar – his performance in the drama
Tinker Tailor Soldier Spy.
Oldman is a generational talent; it’s hard
to believe Commissioner Gordon from The Dark
Knight once played Sid Vicious or was the
villain in The Professional.
He always commands one’s attention with
his dedication to his parts and constantly
knocks it out of the park.
Hopefully one day the right script comes across
his desk and the Academy can make up for this
error.
They have a tendency to reward longtime veterans,
so maybe Oldman’s time will come soon.
Samuel L. Jackson
Jackson has built a career featuring one great
performance after another and boasts just
a single Oscar nomination on his résumé
for Pulp Fiction.
Some of his best work has gone overlooked
by the Academy, such as his other Tarantino
collaborations Django Unchained and The Hateful
Eight.
Jackson is known for his shouting, but he’s
more than capable of delivering an emotionally
rich turn.
His performances in films like Black Snake
Moan and Unbreakable are exemplary, and many
would be in agreement that Jackson deserves
an Oscar.
As he balances his time in the MCU with more
“prestigious” roles, maybe his fortunes
will change eventually.
Glenn Close
Close holds an Academy record, and not the
kind one would want.
She’s been nominated six times in her career,
which is the most without securing at least
one win.
Close is an extremely versatile performer,
playing a wide range of characters over the
years.
She’s received recognition for playing a
crazy stalker in Fatal Attraction, a woman
passing herself as a man in Albert Nobbs,
and everything in between.
She’s clearly one of a kind and has been
waiting a long time for her name to be called.
You’d think she’ll eventually break through,
since she’s established as a legend who
has proven her worth time and time again.
Robert Downey, Jr.
RDJ is firmly entrenched as the face of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe, but cinephiles
know his talents go well beyond playing Tony
Stark.
Downey has turned in numerous outstanding
performances, earning two Oscar nominations
along the way.
His first came in the biopic Chaplin, where
he played the film’s namesake.
He also famously was a Best Supporting Actor
candidate for his controversial turn as Kirk
Lazarus in Tropic Thunder, and might have
won if it wasn’t also the year Heath Ledger
was in The Dark Knight.
Though Downey may never win for being Iron
Man, the Academy may look to reward him if
the right role comes his way.
He’s a fan-favorite and well liked in the
industry.
Tom Cruise
Before he went into full action hero mode,
Tom Cruise was one of the better dramatic
actors out there, earning praise for his turns
in films like Rain Man and A Few Good Men.
He’s been nominated three times in his career:
Born on the Fourth of July, Jerry Maguire,
and Magnolia.
Regardless of what one things of his personal
life, Cruise is fiercely dedicated to his
craft, and if he took a break from Jack Reacher
and Ethan Hunt to go back to drama, he could
clinch himself an Oscar win.
Cruise’s main goal is to constantly make
movies general audiences enjoy, but he certainly
wouldn’t turn down an Academy Award if one
came his way.
Michael Keaton
Keaton has had a starring role in the last
two Best Picture winners, Birdman and Spotlight,
but he remains without an Oscar of his own.
In fact, despite multiple outstanding performances,
he’s only been nominated once.
Many had pegged Keaton as the favorite for
Best Actor in 2014, the year of Birdman, but
it was strictly a sentimental choice of moviegoers.
Keaton lost to Eddie Redmayne, who played
Stephen Hawking in The Theory of Everything.
Keaton is back at it this year as McDonald’s
founder Ray Kroc in The Founder, and he could
have another shot if everything falls into
place.
Three other Batmen are Oscar winners, so why
not make it four?
Viola Davis
Davis has been nominated twice in her long,
successful career for her turns in Doubt and
The Help.
She’s been delivering powerful performance
after powerful performance for more than a
decade, and now the Academy is starting to
take notice.
Though she remains without an Oscar – few
can stop the Meryl Streep train when that
gets rolling – many believe Davis’ time
is coming shortly.
She stars alongside Academy favorite Denzel
Washington in this year’s Fences, reprising
a role that earned her a Tony award during
the stage production.
If the film is anything like the play, she
could end up on the stage on Oscar night.
Harrison Ford
An icon thanks to his geek-friendly roles
of Han Solo and Indiana Jones, Ford is a strong
actor and can be much more than a charming
rogue.
He’s earned one Oscar nomination in his
storied career, playing a cop gone hiding
in an Amish village in Witness.
The Golden Globes are fonder of his talents,
giving Ford four Best Actor nominations – including
Best Picture nominee The Fugitive - and the
Cecil B. DeMille Award in 2012.
His legacy in films is without question, but
it would please many to see Ford’s status
as one of the all-time greats cemented with
an Academy Award.
He’s free from Star Wars now, so maybe he
can chase gold until he retires.
Those are just some of the actors who are
overdue for an Oscar win.
Are there any we missed?
Which ones do you hope receive an Academy
Award one day?
Sound off in the comments below and be sure
to subscribe to our channel for more fun videos.
Thanks for watching!